so
back to what i was saying before
my theory oh god um steve rogers did not
have a girlfriend before he went into
the service
says who
the history channel so he becomes
captain america and from that moment on
a symbol of america he is rushed to the
front lines he becomes a war hero then
he is frozen in ice right so based on
everything you've told me um after he
gets unfrozen he goes from world
threatening disaster to world
threatening disaster that's when he's
not a fugitive from the law right so it
seems like he was pretty pretty busy all
you're doing is repeating everything
that i've already told you about my
friend and colleague obviously captain
america was a virgin
in the marvel cinematic universe the
people are protected by two separate yet
equally important groups the heroes who
save them and the attorneys who clean up
their collateral damage but only one can
be both this is her story dun dun
lawyer show
she holds a legal comedy like we've
never done before
all rise
he's back now all right aura calm down
what's fun is the types of marvel
characters that come to her for legal
advice no judge is gonna take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book oh
the book of the shanty no the book of
american uh loss
[Music]
it's a law show like ali mcbeal or
practice
and then it breaks all those rules
the fun of the show is to combine this
legal world and all of the possibilities
around
superhero weirdness
call my lawyer
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer
we're really pushing boundaries other
shows haven't before
case closed
done done
you